do you want to play a spider-man or
Wolverine in a super-powered action RPG
but you don't have a PC well then you'll
be happy to hear that a free to play
Marvel hero spin-off is coming to
consoles this year there's also a bunch
of other details including a closed beta
I'm Matt and this GameSpot news update
is here to save the day
Marvel heroes Omega is an action RPG
like Diablo that draws inspiration from
MMOs as well it features characters from
all over the Marvel Universe including
spider-man The Avengers and the x-men in
addition to villains such as Loki and
Doctor Doom
unfortunately however Marvel heroes
players on PC won't be able to transfer
their accounts or play with those on
console we also don't have a specific
release date for Omega but we will be
able to keep you up to date as long as
you hit those like and subscribe buttons
Marvel heroes Omega releases on the ps4
first with the Xbox one version coming
later a closed beta will kick things off
on the ps4 and we'll make sure to report
back when that start date gets announced
but hey all of you Xbox one players out
there don't worry you'll get your own
closed beta as well make sure to keep
your eye on gamespot comm for any
updates on this and if you want to watch
some Super Heroes beat each other up
check out the official breakdowns of the
flash and Captain colt
from injustice 2
[Music]